[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Hardware is back this is the Asus
Zenfone 6. this is one of the bigger
surprises for phones this year coming in
at 500 bucks so this isn't a full review
of the cell phone it's more of an
impressions of what's turned into yet
another way to avoid the Notch and
what's ended up being one of the more
interesting impressive mid-range phones
of 2019. so the Zenfone 6 has a 6.4 inch
full HD Plus IPS LCD display rounded
Corners as you can see but of course no
Notch no cutouts no hole punch no
interruptions now the ads show it as
this kind of Glorious full screen
display from edge to edge and corner to
corner you know it's a little more of a
chin and a bezel than that but we'll go
with it so how do they achieve this in a
500 phone and where do they put that
front-facing stuff well the fingerprint
reader they didn't put under the glass
it's still on the back and I still like
this it's lower and sort of in the
middle so it's super reachable it's
right where my finger naturally rests
it's the same place I like it on the
pixel phones and the earpiece speaker is
still up in this little slot here at the
top alongside actually an LED
notification light which is rare
nowadays there isn't much customization
to it but I like that it's there and
then the selfie camera well you've seen
it by now it's the main camera flipped
around it's kind of great it's this
massive chassis with dual cameras that
sort of flips around when you go to
selfie mode and takes the front-facing
shot and it's not quite either those
Motors make a sound every time
but believe it or not this is not the
first camera or phone that I've used to
do this back in 2013 I actually reviewed
What's called the Oppo N1 this gigantic
phone running CyanogenMod with like the
world's largest forehead and chin and a
13 megapixel camera in this Barb at the
top that doubled as your selfie camera
if you swiveled it around the main
difference of course was this one was
manual so you swiveled it around with
your hands like a caveman but uh yeah
this one from Asus in 2019 is electronic
it's motorized and like I said it's
actually dual cameras so you have a 48
megapixel F 1.8 main sensor and a 13
megapixel Ultra wide as well and then
because it's motorized you have all
kinds of extra features but also all
kinds of other stuff to worry about so
first of all don't expect this to be
water resistant anymore there's no IP
rating for this phone and I just don't
think you'd want to get any water near
this piece anyway and even duster dirt
getting in there could eventually be an
actual problem so you got to be careful
with it and then of course there's no
way you want anything to impact it or
have anything bend it the motor already
makes some pretty concerning noises when
it encounters any resistance
but like I said the motor actually gives
you the ability to do a bunch of other
interesting things the first being the
volume rocker isn't a shutter button
anymore it's actually a controller to
control the exact precise angle that you
want that camera to flip up at any given
time which is fascinating and then the
software button becomes a slider to do
the same thing so now you have this fine
control over the exact angle of this
swiveling camera chassis at any time I
don't know if that becomes kind of
useful or just kind of creepy that you
can hold it at whatever angle you want
but it seems firmly in the gimmick
bucket to me at least that feature but
then in panorama mode there is a fully
automatic Panorama tilt so if you can
take a vertical or horizontal Panorama
by just hitting the button and it uses
the motors to move the lens for you
across the frame this is actually kind
of useful I could see someone just
holding the phone perfectly still and
it'll spin up to a full 180 degrees to
flat or until you tell it stop
essentially maximizing your Panorama
quality now I don't know how often you
take panoramas personally I don't do
this a ton but it works really well and
it's kind of hilarious that you can get
yourself into the Panorama if you let it
flip all the way around so that that is
a clever use of the motor and then there
is object tracking mode so if you're
trying to take a video or something
without moving the phone of a subject
you can have it latch on to what what
looks like just contrast based object
detection and then as long as that
subject moves to the left basically the
camera can swivel over and keep it in
the frame as long as you keep that video
going for me this was pretty finicky
from my experience since the contrast
based detection isn't perfect but I
guess I could see people taking videos
maybe of themselves using this and it
also has drop protection as well so you
remember how the OnePlus would sort of
retract the selfie camera if it detected
free fall this one if it detects free
fall
we'll just snap back that camera where
it was to avoid it you know Landing
weird and crunching it
um it actually snaps back a little bit
faster than it normally goes in and out
in regular use which I think is it just
preserving the motor's life but it's
rated for a hundred thousand opens and
closes I feel like I've already opened
and closed it like a thousand times but
that's at least good for a couple years
and then the camera quality itself is
actually pretty good so I gotta be
honest I wasn't expecting much out of
the Zenfone but if the pixels camera is
my a plus then this is a solid B minus
to a b so it's gotten a couple software
updates and there are more coming I
think it's main problem still is dynamic
range and inconsistency like it can't
really be trusted to take a great shot
every time and the ultrawide camera
while it's nice to have really is much
worse than the main camera but the main
camera especially as a selfie camera is
quite good so shots are detailed color
is pretty good uh it's edge to edge
sharp and then when you swivel it around
to face yourself of course that's going
to be right up there is now one of the
best selfie cameras so it's one of the
only ones to actually get real
background blur and depth of field that
isn't fake on a selfie so yeah this
whole camera mechanism by itself is
fascinating but there is of course the
whole rest of the phone here that's
low-key a really nice collection of
choices and pieces to put together for a
500 phone it has a high-end specs
Snapdragon 855 and up to eight gigs of
RAM and it's an all metal and glass
build and it's Hefty like this is a
chunky solid phone and a big part of
that is because it has a 5 000 milliamp
hour battery inside that is absolutely
massive and I think that now makes it
the largest battery cell in a phone I've
ever used it doesn't charge quite as
fast as some others because of the way
the cell is built and it has 18 watt
fast charging and no wireless charging
but that's much more acceptable when you
can imagine how long a 5 000 milliamp
hour battery with a 1080p display will
probably last that's exciting in a phone
by itself and I'm happy that phone
batteries just keep getting bigger at
this rate uh there's also Bluetooth 5.0
there is a headphone jack there's some
pretty good speakers which a lot of
phones in this range don't have a power
button with this ring of blue paint
around it and then it has this extra
button up above the volume rocker that
by default is a Google Assistant button
so you can remap it to a couple other
functions so it's kind of halfway to
being awesome this extra button so
technically yes they let you customize
it but it's with a couple of sort of
quick actions that they've pre-selected
I have single pressed to Google
Assistant double press to open or turn
on the flashlight which is cool
but they don't just let you open
whatever app you want with it that would
have been what I really wanted you know
single press for Google Tasks double tap
for Google Assistant something like that
but you can't do that and then it's also
kind of hard to reach so I love having
these extra customizable buttons but
this one is so high up that you need
sort of a whole hand shimmy just to
reach it I kind of just wish it was on
the other side of the volume rocker
which is blank but hey it's up there so
one of the biggest most welcome changes
on this whole phone is Asus finally
dropping that massive zenui skin and
bringing it way back to near stock
Android dropping all the bloatware all
the unnecessary duplicate apps and the
Ugly launcher and custom icons and
themes and settings and things we didn't
like this is much better much cleaner
and hopefully that spells faster
software updates as well so yeah Zenfone
6. it's definitely one of the surprises
of the Year for me so far of course
being a pretty great all-around budget
phone that happens to have one really
impressive swively camera feature not to
be be clear this is definitely still a
workaround this isn't like the permanent
solution on our way to bezel-less phones
This falls in the category of notches
and hole punch cutouts and pop-up
cameras but it's a pretty cool one I
guess this specific version of it with
the swiveling camera
I don't hate it like it's obviously not
practical for long-term future Solutions
but for me I think I'm a sucker for
camera quality over like anything else
as far as practicality like that's why I
was so into the pixel 3 for so long
despite so many of the issues that it
had so when I saw this one this just
flips around and becomes one of the best
quality selfie cameras instantly that to
me made me kind of like it a lot more
but we'll keep an eye on this phone and
a bunch more coming in the future but as
far as I can tell definitely a pretty
great all-around 500 phone but let me
know would you would you get a phone
with a swiveling camera like this would
you be into it let me know in the
comments section below either way thanks
for watching catch you guys in the next
one
peace